you ever meet an overachiever somebody
who performs out a complete different
level and immediately you feel their
presence you know what I'm talking about
you're like why is he thinking that way
why is he wired that way why is his
energy this way why does he think this
way - dude is weird right okay anyone
you ever meet that competes at a whole
different level
they generally in their imagination they
have multiple personalities that they
either viewed themselves at or people
from other spaces and industries that
they respect and admire that gets them
to be wired the way they are let me
explain to what I mean by this a lot of
people ask me they say path you know you
think different you say things and
there's a lot of guys online but when
you talk it comes from different what
what do you like who do you admire who
do you look up to how do you get your
inspiration yourself and I said that is
such a great question I chose to again
turn it into another episode Believe It
or Not you guys make all all my episodes
and I said five identities of an
entrepreneur can I'll explain to exactly
what I mean by that the first one when I
chose to compete at a high level I was a
regular entrepreneur doing nothing just
a regular chump entrepreneur that
thought he was so special and one month
I made some money and I thought I was on
top of the world and I went to Vegas
gamble I so was boom boom boom boom I
thought entrepreneurship was about the
girls party in Vegas nightclub all this
stuff and you go with your friends and
open up hey bar drinking nope I wanted
to compete I really wanted to go to
whole different level so one day I had a
time out and I said Pat you've chosen
this industry yes what are the mindsets
of other professionals and different
worlds do you want to emulate and I
wrote down the five and let me take
exactly what the fiber number one was an
athlete
number one was an athlete I always grew
up respecting athletes I grew up
watching magic I grow watching Jordan I
grew up watching Juan Gonzalez okay who
play for the Rangers two-time MVP 46
home runs you almost broke hack Wilson's
record one time for RBIs I grew up
watching Kobe I grew up watching Van
Exel I grew up watching Sergei Fedorov
Jaromir Jagr Mario Lemieux you know Rob
Blake Marty McSorley Gretzky
I grew up watching these guys and I grew
up admiring these competitors right
Frank Thomas bond
it was just McGuire was fascinating I
was in the Army I remember McGwire and
Sammy Sosa went for the homerun record
in 1998 we were in a military going not
staying up too late not just to see boom
when they were doing their things I have
the paper till today when McGwire and
Sosa broke the record so I always
respected it athletes and I said so
Patton why do you respect athletes I
have a few points here on why every
entrepreneur should learn these things
from athletes I've six points for you
first one was this it was work ethic and
I'll take exactly what I mean by work
ethic for me work ethic goes to baseball
and I'll tell you why baseball I looked
at Cal Ripken jr. as somebody every
entrepreneur needs to emulate Cal Ripken
jr. was a baseball player who played for
Baltimore Orioles number eight he didn't
hit the most homeruns he did 20 home
runs
18 home runs things like that 82 RBIs he
was a good player but he was a leader
there was something about the guy that
was a leader he was a locker room guy he
was a guy that you want representing
your brand he was a face of a company he
was a face of Major League Baseball
great face for that I'll tell you why
this guy played he broke a record that
probably I don't know if it's going to
be broken for a long time to come 56
year record and Major League Baseball of
Lou Gehrig who played for the Yankees
Lou Gary played 2130 games in a row
without missing a single game now it's
exactly why that's so important every
year in baseball they play 162 games per
year they play 81 at home so let's just
say if I'm play for the Texas Rangers
81 is in Texas 81 is not in Texas now
think about that
81 home 81 on the road because that
means I'm traveling all the time going
to different cities not that staying at
hotels all these sorts of things right
added 162 games we're not including
preseason we're not including playoff so
if you go into playoffs you could play
16 more games or 20 more games or having
many depending on how deep you go in the
class or preseason practice and it
doesn't include offseason right Lou Gary
56 years
record Stan's the guy plays 2130 games
in a row Cal Ripken jr. breaks that
record he does 2131 games the game he
breaks the record
Bill Clinton comes to recognize him
because Bill Clinton the president
cannot believe how an athlete plays 2131
give the entire stadium lights to place
up the players push him out and say dude
go out there the fans want to shake your
hands he's so humble he doesn't want to
come out said go out there he goes out
you just go and put his hand up and do
one of these things he notices know
everybody wants to shake his hands like
I'm getting the chills on my arms here
everybody want to shake his hand and he
goes around he's just - is like no no
everyone says arm is out just pay
attention to the scene ruko watch this
20-second scene here
you know after my handshake to and
shakes to MOOCs in the face then all of
a sudden
intimate of a celebration
to know
enjoy work
how powerful is that everybody wants to
shake this guy's hands and he comes back
and everyone's flabbergasted
listen there's a part of the story most
people don't know he was married during
that time him and his wife had three
kids and on one of the pregnancies his
wife is in a hospital who's in labor in
the hospital in labor while he's playing
baseball and in baseball you got to play
five innings for it to count as a game
his wife said go to the game go to the
game she supported the record he ghosted
again everybody in the stands knows his
wife's in the hospital everybody's
clapping and then when fifth inning
comes he runs out everyone's in tears
emotional he goes in his baby's born the
entire family the entire Major League
Baseball knew and wanted this guy to win
by the way he ended up playing 2600 I
believe 32 games that's 16 years they
don't miss a single game out of
conversation one of the entrepreneurs on
Monday he and I spoke on the phone for
45 minutes and they decided to take a
day off on Memorial Day on certain
things that's all you know what we did
this on wheat you know and I said you
took a day off on the last year this is
close you're in sales you're not true
your business what do you mean take it
since well you know I just man I totally
messed up we totally screwed up man I'm
so upset with my soul of this energy
because he at least came from a place of
saying I want to hire mice instead of
fine so I can do whatever I want to do
can't tell me what to do he came from a
place of I want to raise my game now why
why let me get to my next point next
point on why that was so important on
why I wanted to look and think perform
like an athlete athletes always play on
days everyone takes a day off athletes
play on Christmas Day see on Christmas
is everyone's home opening up gifts all
this other stuff Kobe LeBron Jordan
Jordan my all these guys they're playing
on Christmas Day while everyone's at
home with their kids they're performing
on a date because their players
everyone's fans at home they're
performing Memorial Day brie ball it's
Memorial Day barbecue barbecue people
forget what really Memorial Day is all
about
Memorial Day isn't for you now have a
barbecue Memorial Day is much bigger
than that
but a memorial it's so great so how men
for Day weekend it's so great I hit my
up really no Memorial Day baseball
players play on Memorial Day basketball
players play on Memorial Day it's sports
ok 4th to July they play New Year's
thanksgiving baseball turkey ball
Cowboys Redskins you know Detroit you
know these teams that play they play
Philly they play this is tradition they
play
I love the mindset of an athlete because
athletes play on the days that average
employees and regular people want to
take those days off I don't want to be
the spectator that's why it's an
antitrust I don't want to be the guy
that just wants to take those days off I
don't want to do that everyone can I'm
not judging anybody who does I refuse to
that because it's not my standards I
chose to change it up at 23 24 25 years
old next one staying in shape athletes
have to stay in shape you don't stay in
shape you lose why do you need to stay
in shape it's a competitive environment
everybody wants your position you think
you're playing good but guess what you
put on what you're out Bynum you think
you're a big shot you're out all these
guys are coming to Lincoln they put on
weight you're out all the time so many
athletes have come put on weight they're
done in every single sports you got a
stain ship as an entrepreneur practice
is very big as an entreprenuer edge you
got to do your shots you know whatever
it is it's constant practice the other
one is interviews you know I'm more
interested in interviews than the actual
game believe it or not like you will see
me you know on my phone at 11:30 at
night watching the interviews of what an
athlete says or what somebody said I
want to watch a 90 second interview I
want to watch a two-minute interview I
want to watch a three-minute interview
that's what I'm interested in because I
want to know how they handle the loss
how to handle the victory how to handle
somebody talking smack about them I want
to I want to see how they communicate
with their competitors how they took it
from the coach challenging them and the
players saying well coach is right we
need to step up and we didn't follow the
game plan that the coaches put in place
and how the coaches defend the players
or take the heat or sometimes the great
coaches like Phil Jackson calls out
Jordan calls out Kobe and they see how
they respond and then I want to see the
interviews because I see how their minds
it is the athlete then the next one is a
competitor I mean I love the fire of a
competitor you look at competition your
sports curry Jordan Westbrook
Kobe you know the guy who plays for a
Washington Nationals harperman guys got
some fire in him
you know Oh d'Or Bautista that
hole-punch with the door hit Bautista in
the face after the slide I mean there's
something about that competitive nature
that you gotta love I love that guy
who's the UFC guy who is the UFC guy
that the the guy that from UK he's an
incredible fighter you know what I'm
talking about
he was a cover of Sports Illustrated I'm
fascinated by competitors I am
fascinated by Ali I am fascinated by
these guys and I think sometimes as an
entrepreneur you need a source of
inspiration go watch a video with Jordan
and the Knicks just put Michael Jordan
Knicks it's a four-minute video I
guarantee you'll be inspired go type in
coach a mike ditka interview look at all
the times on how he talks smack you'll
get fired up on these guys on how bad
they wanted to compete so number one
identity to me is a athlete let's talk
about the second identity second
identity to me on how I treated my
business as an entrepreneur was being a
head coach how do head coaches think and
I'll say exactly what I meant head coach
because I looked at a head coach that
had to learn a few different things from
building a team conflicts when nobody
gets along with each other on the team
you got to create unison alignments
people willing to be coachable you know
being willing to ask people to leave the
team how do you do that you know being
willing to recruit other people to your
team how do you do that selling the
possibility of us doing it how do you
challenge your players how do you get
people to rise up how do you put
somebody on the bench and see how
they're going to respond how do you
realize one guy's just not a lead guy
you keep trying to get this guy to be
the captain of the team he's not a
captain type of guy he just wants to be
left alone and play there was a time
where Lamar Odom was playing for the
Lakers as a starter he hated being a
starter he just wanted to be a six-man
finally he just said let me be a six-man
he became a six-man and eight they want
a championship Steve Kerr comes to
Golden State Warriors he has a guy named
Andre Iguodala who's always been a
starter averaging 23 24 points against
Steve says you got to sit on the bench
we out of your mind
I've always started you're sitting on
the bench go sits on the bench becomes
the MVP of the final
going against Cleveland Cavaliers
guarding the great LeBron James
that's coaching Steve Kerr's a great
coach Joe Torre you look at some of
these guys when you watch coaches you
know when you look at feel when you look
at all these other guys you're running
on how their coach and you're learning
on how they're injecting believed
strategies calming people down when need
it it's okay you've been playing this
game all your life you know what you're
doing quit fooling yourself and making
it a bigger deal you play basketball
since six years old it's the same game
it's alright go pull it off you can do
this expectation standards building
leaders I wanted to think like a coach I
watched great coaches on how they let
their business and I brought that into
my business as an entrepreneur the next
one was a CEO and I know you like well
isn't an entrepreneur so you're not
necessarily an entrepreneur you may
start off as somebody that's an
independent contractor selling something
and then but I wanted to think like a
CEO a lot of people are so proud to be a
CEO entitle anyone can be called the CEO
anybody you can call yourself whatever
you want I mean you can go on YouTube
right now and call yourself a business
guru and there's no regulations against
it you can do that you can go online
right now and talk about a millionaire
coach I mean there's so many people
calling a millionaire coach they're
barely making $36,000 a year but they're
millionaire coaches right you can do
that you can get away with that but I
wanted to know real CEOs okay I wanted
to know how they thought I wanted to
know how Bezos how Ellison Larry Ellison
from Oracle whose company in the 90s in
the 80s did 100% every single year for
10 years Larry Ellison was worth 49
billion bucks when a co-founder of
Oracle why CEO because vision what's
next move what's your next audible
finance money can we afford it can we
not afford it leadership responsibility
taking the heat CEO good things happens
you got to give credit away if mad
things happens your fault you know when
the CEO of Apple was going that oh it's
always Steve Jobs okay good things
happen well it's not really Steve Jobs I
came up with the iPhone it doesn't
matter it always goes that way right so
I
accountability accountability comes with
CEO day today with no breaks you're not
a see only five days away your CEO seven
days a week I wanted to be and think
like that even when I was somebody who
was in my third fourth you're not not do
the act but just think like a CEO I
don't need to do the activities of you
know quarterly call investors calls no
no I want to think I want to have the
mindset of that CEO right next one next
one this one's going to sound the next
two are going to sound a little strange
to you okay fourth identity was a leader
of a nation let me tell you what I mean
by a leader of a nation I I always
wanted to think okay if you're running a
country
how would you lead this country now why
a leader of a nation why would you want
to think like a leader and it's not kind
of egotistical like who do you think you
are you think you're gonna be a
president you think you know you think
you're a rule you think you're governor
you think you're like a prime who do you
think you are man you're just a what a
leader of a nation let me explain to you
why I think an entrepreneur building a
company ought to be thinking like a
leader of a nation because your values
and principles that you speak and do if
your values and principles that you talk
about are aligned with your behavior
everybody else replicates it if your
value sense principles that you talk
about are not aligned with your behavior
everyone laughs behind your back they
just don't tell you about in your face
let me say that one more time the values
and principles of a leader of a nation
if it's aligned with his behavior
everyone replicates if it's not you
become a laughingstock and you're on SNL
every week is what you are okay the
other part about a leader of a nation
was speaking with enemy how do you
compete with a speaker would communicate
with an enemy how do you handle enemy
how do you handle somebody that hates
you how do you handle somebody that
wants to build an alliance at another
Asia Asian you know as another nation
how do you build that alliance with them
right how do you partner up with another
nation that's got things going on that
they can give you or you can give them
crop you can give them there's a certain
trade going on how do you handle that
right system of a economical system you
know this may sound like what do you
mean eken
amical system because desert an
entrepreneur automatically be a
capitalist you'd be amazed how many
entrepreneurs actually run their
business like a communist you'd be
amazed how many entrepreneurs owned a
business like a social so it may explain
to what it means when they do very well
it's how we did it together it was so
great what we did it was all we we we we
we but then nobody gets individual
recognition right it's all we only so
the guy that pushed a little harder he
doesn't get recognition I want to so as
America I think today we're a lot about
only we we we we we I don't know how
much we're recognizing innovators I
don't know how much we're recognizing
the individuals that are doing more than
a majority I think we need to recognize
them their luck and basketball they have
MVP playoff MVP of rookie the all this
stuff the team wins a championship but
who's the playoff MVP who's a
championship MVP who's a rookie here we
need to have the individual accolade so
as a leader of a nation they also
recognize individual do you run a
recognition economical system that's
more recap ballistic recognition is that
socialism everybody is great or the
communism no one can do more than the
other person everyone is be treated
equally that's a there's a big
difference between treated fairly and
equally and when you're running a nation
you may say one thing but your behavior
could be complete completely
contradicting the way that you believe
it should be ran you'll know a lot about
how you run your country your nation
your business pride there's a lot of
pride in your nation you know how you
deliver your message during good and bad
times everybody's watching you're on
camera all the time what's your gonna
say about what just happened
what's your gonna say about this person
what's he gonna say about that you're
everybody's watching you oh oh
leader of a nation how my god did you
see what happened what's he gonna say
you right and then your example then
trust and print transparency this is all
part of being an entrepreneur that
creates a big following I'll tell you
the last one year the last one years
gonna sound strange as well the last one
is on where I got my inspiration was
thinking about somebody who is about to
lose everything somebody who is being
chased by somebody now where did that
feeling and emotion come from for me
you know when I lived in Iran and there
was always that fear of being attacked
by Saddam and all this other cell by
Iraq and lived there 10 years and it
created this someone's after us
someone's after us
and so what emotion does that create it
created being alert I think if you don't
think someone's after you you're you
don't have your guards up and you're not
ready and you're not alert I think when
9/11 happened to America a big part of
it was because we were not alert we were
not ready we were not expecting that we
were not fully prepared to protect our
nation and the World Trade Center and
all this other stuff and then BOOM and
event like that took place because we
were not alert oh it's never going to
happen to America oh it's never going to
happen to us why would it ever happen to
America and then boom were shot America
I mean this is United States of America
that this takes place too I mean I
remember why I was that I was working on
World Trade Center on our headquarters
was in World Trade Center I was working
in Glendale Morgan Stanley Dean Witter
and the Morgan Stanley headquarters was
at the World Trade Center I remember
that I remember those days
maybe we were not alert enough you know
maybe you're doing so well in the
business and you all are saying you
become so comfortable and you lose
everything what happened you were not
alert you didn't catch that coming and
another person couldn't wait to take
your lunch and if you think that's not
how it is in business you're fooling
yourself that alertness somebody could
come after you could come and take
everything you got you better believe
the sames got to go with your family now
I understand faith and trusting and
positive thinking and all that other
stuff but as much positive thinking I
want to have in faith if I don't have my
guards up when I'm fighting you and you
catch me boom I'm gone I can believe in
faith and anything I'm knocked out
believing in faith make sense you got to
be also doing your part you know you got
to be doing your part as well so when
you're thinking about someone who's
after you and someone who's about to
lose everything this keeps me in the
game more instead of me being
comfortable it keeps a healthy amount of
paranoia it gets me to be improving I am
more alert I'm more
where you now watch the video the other
day by a guy named dr. something I miss
about this a picture here doctor this
guy who was in Spain okay and I may be
completely telling you the story
amigo Institute this guy named dr. dan
Siegel okay
he told this story where he said when he
was in Spain he was riding a horse and
he falls off a horse on the bottom and
the horse drags him and he loses all his
teeth everything he Lula's loses all his
teeth everything he loses every single
thing broken face arm everything okay
and then they get him and he comes back
up and he's alert but for 24 hours when
he's alert he doesn't remember his own
identity what am I going with this let
me explain to where I'm going with this
he doesn't remember that he's white we
think we're we say I'm Middle Eastern
I'm white all this other stuff what if
we didn't know what Middle Eastern was
he doesn't know he's white he doesn't
know he wears glass he doesn't know what
bald is he's bald he doesn't know how
old he is cuz you don't know like he's
like he says when I came back I couldn't
believe like I was I was my identity was
so cold slate
I had no fears I had nothing going out
all this stuff that it was pretty good I
was clear I was clean I was all this
other stuff now why am I telling you the
story right now
I think because you and I can choose to
create whatever identity we want to
create for ourselves and you can allow
the world to create an identity for you
but at any point you can drop your bad
habits and replace them with good ones
you can drop your low standards and
replace it with high standards you can
go from being a lazy person and become a
hustler if you choose to choose to a lot
of people this morning we had a
conference call with a group of guys
that was coaching they said I said you
know I believe everybody can change but
it's so strange only if you do only if
you do
positively only if you do why takes work
it takes effort it takes discipline it
takes day to day so for me if you truly
want to compete at the highest level
truly want to compute at a highest level
you got to be thinking about like an
athlete think like an athlete you
got to think like a head coach to build
leaders around you you got to think like
a CEO you got to think like a leader of
a nation that casts a vision builds the
right values and principle keeps people
together and you got to think like
somebody who's about to lose everything
to keep you in and keep you alert and
keep you on edge and keep you going in a
way that you're going to hold it from
when everybody else is thinking you
can't get to that point you can and if
you do so you perform at a whole
different level your competitors will
treat you in respect in a complete
different way the people that are
working with you will follow you in a
whole different way and talent around
the world who wants to work with you
will call you endlessly to say how do I
work with you on a daily basis I just
want to be in business with you
just like all these other guys that are
recruiting people and we're getting
hundreds of calls and messages saying
how can we what can we do to be part of
this group that you're building and what
can we do to be part of it when you when
you when you go in at that level and
you're wired at that level you're
competing at that level some strange
things happen so that's my challenge to
you on to be thinking about those five
identities you may want to watch this
video again earlier once you throw me my
favorite pillow here we need your help
guys we need your help we had our
biggest subscription day last week in
one day we had 660 subscribers we need
to get to a hundred thousand subs by
August 31st and we need your help lots
of you come in every single video saying
we love this YouTube channel awesome how
do I pay back help us get 200,000 subs
by August 31st 100,000 subscribers by
August 31st I think while you're
watching this if you look at the bottom
the number I think about 42 thousand
subscribers as of today maybe by the
time you watch you read something else
but as of today what our 42 thousand
subscribers help us get as many
entrepreneurs subscribing to this
channel as possible
and so if you haven't subscribed to the
channel click on the bottom right here
give us us up Javan yet there you go
thank you and if you're watching this
video on a complete different website
you can always come back to Patrick
Madhavi com you go Pat ready be calm and
you'll have a lot more resources there
and videos to follow and watch thanks
for watching everybody take care bye bye